l a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
video sono falli j
oggi siamo su sia la sua outlast sono
entrati questa porta entrato al trota
non pensavo si potesse entrare in questa
forza fantastico dove eravamo rimasti
ragazzi che stanno correndo la dei
brutti ceffi prassi come non posso
riprendere da quel punto perché come
cazzo di prendono al punto in cui mi
ricordo non vi dirò come è finita
mi hanno stuprato male devo trovare
perché non lo ricordasse il generatore
dell'ascensore che c'è un ascensore
indietro non so perché casa già stato
finalmente gira fa la sua comparsa anche
in auto il problema ragazzi che se
cuasso di qua da questa bella porta c'è
questo bel uomo che ce lo ricorda ecco
che mi segue vuole stuprarmi che l'hanno
cosa molto simpatica questo salve dov'è
che lo stato di qua ma si può dare quel
senso perché entra in trance è chiuso a
loro vanno a seguito ma sono scemi che
soprattutto mi hanno seguito per maps ma
meno male non facciamoci domanda meno
male ciao katy perry stai pregando al
connubio scoppi navas elettori come tua
madre [ __ ] questo mettendo i commenti
porca [ __ ] che il calcio fortissimo a
posto guardate giunsi ma fa di peggio
nella wwe ha comunque mi avete detto nei
commenti
tanto questa agonizzante la cia ago
avete letto nei commenti che questo tipo
è
il capo di questa setta satanica che si
chiama papà lo dicono ogni tanto quando
parla non servisse [ __ ] e lo
dico come che si chiama parla o donna
possa farci una scala grazia di un
l'avevo vista ciò piano che qua mi
chiami assaltano come niente paura
generator rom
mi piace ho fatto ciò patito le pene
inferno 4s ha fatto da stanza se non si
apre agli schiaffi di dear howard come
si accende qualcuno perché soprattutto
angelica storia di aranzulla su come
accendere il generatore del di una città
fantastica ha dato si si vede proprio in
tempo reale accesso e luce fu
sbaglierò avete visto voi costante mori
che correrà la tua magar [ __ ] è esatto
esatto tra mia stessa reaction non me
l'aspettavo mai poi ho mai un bello e
sto gioco ma emigrati fa che ho calciato
prima ora che sia non volevo è sito che
mai al credito vuoi un calcione sul
fegato anche tu sia questa c'è un
coltellino ragazzi o questa eviterei
così magari sappiamo sappiamo i nostri
saltiamo giu salta giusto per febbraio a
che perfetto va bene così
tutta la tua sorella fa il gol di quella
non mi può vedere se i premi [ __ ]
tanto lo seminata non so se lo seminato
ho fatto lo stesso giro che ho fatto la
merda
c'è una porta access non c'è una forza
non di giorni che sono e cosa ne corsano
con ricordi zio colli madonna che mia
non è più agile un ace però mai fatto
dentro questa 6 fuoco atletico madonna
rega mi chiama fi jody la mattina
madonna cori con un puledro morto ma
come fai a ricordo arrivo nella nella
dentro l'acqua tra l'altro che deve
uscire se non muoio porca eva lo
trattenere il respiro ditemi voi se lo
fa stabilità
dal deretano alla mandibola signore cosa
cava piano mi chiamino male
visto dai che quale madama come piazze
fatto dai ma come ha fatto nei posta non
è possibile
forse ci arrivo cicchitto cazzo cazzo
mai vederlo cettina tirate a tutto nel
buio tutto tondo lancio non ci voglio
credere raga non ci posso avere cioè
cos'è successo
va bene non facciamoci domando come si
cura
poi ci si cura non ci si cura importante
che ho salvato giamaica non ci voglio
credere
non era il meno possibile ce l'ha fatta
davvero salve come 14 cazzo sono
contenti se non l'ho fatto a salvarvi lo
è possibile c'è attenzione occhietti
belli a ciò che vedete ma sei drogato
118 attenzione manin e belle a ciò che
fate ma che canzone brutta è questo
ma che cazzo sono vivo cosa vecchia è
successo
no fermi non ho capito la e sfruttato un
polipo da un pozzo dei mi ha trascinato
in un condotto e te pareva e non tornava
a scuola ma lo sapevo io tanto non siamo
soli mi chiama ne sono accorto c'è un
top list c'è il kraken non tantino buio
e corridoio [ __ ]
porca eva sapevo jessica come jessica ma
io continuo a non capire la gamma sono
sogni questi non capisco se il sogno o
meno non si capisce
fa che lo dico io frate devo
necessariamente passare di qua bene in
questa porta non mi toccare ti denuncio
la famiglia workers caw kat roja e corri
corri alzati non vedete che continuano
ad intervallare la scuola color crema
ciao piacere
continuano ad intervallare le scene
della scuola con le scene di dove sono
in mezzo a questa gente non capisco se
un sogno o meno cibo veloce come posso
chiedere che chiude chiodi che grazie
alla turchia serratura melo su chi meno
si mi dispiace zio la vita è questa però
ma posso nascondermi
siccome questo sfonda come niente
perfetto vai vai vai fatto col team a
sfondare sfonda anche tua madre so
colonne non mi spunta dal soffitto lo so
eccola
se però c'era c'è chi dice no non ci
credo non ci posso credere
maran era lo stesso
ahia ahia ha fatto leggermente male io
penso fosse lo stesso non sono andato
avanti
posso passare filippo vai vai frazione
madonna quanto sei lento come la morte
proprio
sono gli uomo nella piazzetta si è
aperta a portare prima chiusa vai dentro
e oggi e gori la serratura c'è qua si si
si
perfetto non è ancora finita sicuro
quindi lo muovere il culo perfetto mai
con i succhi tutto l'anno
dove vado quello che cazzo ma risse e
inter schifoso
gli ho detto che amy ha minacciato di
morte ok numero segno salve testimoni di
geova
e stato bello potrai sempre belli
contrasta gente se ti muovi mi fai prima
bianco ton masso buttano tua madre bye
bye bye bye bye bye non si può uscire di
calabria finestra cazzo perché mi
trovassi aprirsi situazioni di merda e
come faccio per la scheda di sottilette
mai visto
[Applauso]
lo stesso
bye bye bye bye velocisti
beh vabbè allora quanta gente dove sono
un bad un cazzo ti chiudi chiudi per
l'amor di dio
ok ma da una chiara si allarma di roma
dubai
mica a narnia narnia
tieni premuto per sbircia ma che
sbirciare mi uccidono anche alla
famiglia ecco bella cagata che ho fatto
non sembra esserci nessun ente ore di
teoria
porca [ __ ] visto mai
per chiudi chiudi tutto chiudi mi
chiamerà mente tutte quante a una
serratura sono cugat
io mi salvavo d'affetto che c'è qualcosa
per nascondersi no spingi punto spese
guarda tempo specie madonna molto tempo
per spingere un [ __ ] mobile e mi sta
seguendo sicuro e nutrimi giro vai vai
vai vai vai salve molto sexy
cazzo spingi spingi qualsiasi partorendo
vai tua madre brutta come faccio vedere
che oggi stesso il suicido piuttosto
cazzo siamo ok chef è scelto lo dico io
zio non vigato madonna vanti ansiolitico
questo gioco maledetto sempre sempre
così sempre siamo usciti possa avere un
secondo un secondo di tregua 1 porca
vacca laganà e 12 ore che foto mappe per
ora è già rotto il cazzo raga basta e 12
ore che collo a st
che palle ma bastava ti salva
inseguimento della vita madonna mi sa
che mi conviene buttarmi giù prima che
ok
dove vado corro corro come alex
schwarzer corri ma non di quanto neanche
di qua
muoio addosso
io posso girarmi mentre corrono frigo
citron zaia sotto sotto non su a ya
basta
cazzo e ansiolitico che ti puoi girare
per vederti dietro cazzola sta tornando
lato b davvero prima ma non è la stessa
cosa di prima mi chiamano ma essendo
giro in tondo capshaw proprio dietro
veloce veloce veloce veloce e allora che
parla datemi un [ __ ] secondo l'id di
pausa maledizione uno mi chiedevi
correre il giro di ricorrere come usain
volta dei soccorritori verso la luce dai
carri salta perfetto e dove vado
abbiamo mai scemo tutto truccato è
cazzo sta scendendo che non sono anche
qui dove sto andando io laga fate voi
sta andando a caso completamente videsh
io mi fido di te non posso curarmi
adesso fra di correre corri belletto
questo cori vai entra fianco non ci
voglio credere
ma veramente basta basta è è un ora che
ho passato l'episodio a correre poi
salve chi sei tu sei e c ran e il cirano
ragazzi e sheeran pelato scavo posso
uscire
mica meno male io quando vedo roba per
nascondermi indicato a domanda cacciava
calaita su questo l'altro cadono mi
faccio male e la venda la mette sempre
solo nel braccio non so perché mi faccio
male sempre al braccio
e lascia come gesù vieni perché dai
peccati papà ti ha liberato si tieniti i
tuoi peccati dove c'è la chiesa che un
anno un anno e mezzo abbiamo certo il
quadretto ma dentro perché faccio
trovare pronto uno spirito quella che la
cosa che rompe le palle che non capisci
neanche quando arriva la zia lo capisci
proprio non c'è una torcia
devi andare a qullo il che ti fa anche
più incazzare perché molte volte ti
arriva in faccia internet orche e io
parlo io parlo in un soffritto io parlo
spingi carlos criticarlo vai spingi però
bye bye bye bye bye bye zio vecchio
carico ti voglio che kakà mi che non lo
sapevo che potevo guardarmi dietro cazzo
saperlo 6 con ti spaventi mi sarei preso
di più
mica mi sono risparmiato degli infarti
per aggirare la generazione sono sentito
più di umore e non ci voglio credere
io non ci credo ma questo governo questo
volevo questo volevo
se l'inter chiesa ragazze prima della
chiesa incredibile ci ho messo una vita
intensa per arrivare qua qua chi era
incredibile ha permesso far kakà ganz e
finalmente in chiesa hanno dei quadri
diversi ci abbiamo impiegato tre episodi
interi per arrivare qua
fatevi vedere cosa c'é qua dentro o il
confessionale che parlava ai quarti
giorni mi chiama lavorativi video vuoi
capitao tuffo a mare bari che ormai sono
5 euro grazie no fiscali
ok va bene
prendo un qualcosa che faccia dato
ragazzi ci ha scritto giuda o il sangue
sul pezzo e gli andata ancora bene anche
se gli scrivevano farisei era peggio ti
ammazzo con con l'attaccapanni con lo
zaino la scuola un fine fra
vai vai vai vai bene velocissimo pensavo
corrette stava correndo bene e credevo
non ci avessi voglia di non pensavo non
c'è adesso voglio ricordo c'è la voglia
di gordon brown nasconde mi nascondo
sotto le panche le capre campi sotto nel
confessionale che [ __ ] facciamo
pensato è ormai tardi hanno mai visto
signor prete mi perdoni perché ho
beccato una volta aveva ridato un video
sul cazzo uccidere giuseppe vegas
eccole lui è pure quadro ben crane
[Musica]
dopo il pit
vabbè mica non hanno ammazzato neanche
troppo male pensavo peggio
mi vuole confessare padre perché io ho
peccato
lei mi sembra proprio in grado di
confessarmi dalla sua autorevolezza
dunque quella eccolo del quadro e ragga
il cattivo del gioco bastardo
[Applauso]
accanto bonis e devo andare la miniera
dispiace avrei provato ucciderlo però
[Musica]
vai vai vai veloce veloce veloce devo
andare in miniera ragazzi lo trova la
miniera mentre scappo tra l'altro
fantastico apri apri apri cazzo arriva
veloce affetto bravissimo bravissimo
mica quanto veloce mai mai palacio bravo
migliorarci la prima volta eretico a
fuggire in modo decente più o meno
ancora finita e quindi non deve farlo ok
ma chi è incredibile questo luca ha
posto all whites mi chiama battaglia sky
a fare una fuga decente senza schiattare
26 volte
chi è che ha aperto una porta
c'è non c'è che la chicca il cazzo
succede
ammesso e probabilmente questa è la cosa
più horror di tutto quanto il video
provoca quindi ragazzi spero che questi
episodi di auto xvi sia piaciuto ci
vediamo nel prossimo e che succederanno
ancora le peggio cose tanto vabbè auto
squilli lo sappiamo tutti
quindi ragazzi spero vi sia piaciuto
accorsi ometto mi piace anche la risorsa
che come iniziale senza vestiti steri ci
vediamo al prossimo video e da ragazzi
[Musica]